we have a fraction with numerator 5x  minus 1 and denominator X plus four  which answer choice is equivalent to the  above expression a 5 minus 21 over the  quantity X was 4 B 5 minus 1 over the  quantity X plus four  C five minus one over four D five minus  one all over four  to solve this question a neat trick is  to substitute a convenient value like X  is equal to zero  the given fraction will evaluate to be  negative one over four answer Choice D  evaluates to be four over four C is four  and three-fourths and B is going to be  four and three over four so we can  immediately eliminate answer choices d c  and b and a is the correct answer choice  now if you want it to simplify it  properly you would then need to add and  subtract 20 in the numerator and that  simplifies to be answer Choice a 5 minus  21 all over X Plus 4.